honnêtement je sais pas ce que je vais
faire mon travail est un cauchemar ma
bosse me déteste tu as de doigs
d'exploser de Doig si tu veux mon avis
je pense que tu as juste besoin de Ken
ok répétez tout après moi on s'amuse et
on
s'aimeuse dis-moi ce que toi et tes
copines faites je vaisisiner un festival
culinaire
tell une cabane ou une maison de poupée
c'est l'adresse qui est donné au moins
il y a des volets on fait une vir
surprise avec les filles pour le weekend
tu m'en as parlé avant non Marie tu peux
pas le laisser de parler juste contrarié
ok on avait des trucs de prévus pour ce
weekend avant comme quoi sucer sa petite
tu et lui faire un
steak pour tout dire on est vraiment
sous pression ici est-ce qu' en a une
d'entre vous qui peut faire les choses
correctement pourquo nessz pas de faire
un exercice de respiration raison pour
laquelle on est ici c'est pour que tu
puisses sauver le peu de réputation que
tu penses avoir tu es tellement à fond
dans ta carrière de merde que tu es pas
capable de t'ouvrir aux autres c'est
normal de rencontrer des obstacles ça
fait partie de la
vie il faut que tu sois présente pour
les gens qui t'entourent et que tu aies
confiance dans le fait qu'il te
[Musique]
soutienne
ઓ